[Music]
timmy i'm here what time is it it's 7 26
a.m
timmy i'm here call dr burns
i got her
what do you want for
[Music]
kimmy i'm here reopen my stream on
desktop i need more kitchen paper
open yesterday's stream
[Music]
i'm a voice stream interpreter i may
have heard a crime
on one of the streams the devices pick
up lots of things
just mark this degraded audio and delete
it i am not capable and you know it i
think a woman might need help
how do i find out who she is you need
the device number and the admin code
will you make me one this is the last
favorite question
closure files come to my office we'll
listen to the recordings together
miss childs i have to know what we're
dealing with we're dealing with what
sounds like a premeditated murder
how do i know that because i just told
you
twice now
maybe you've just replaced your real
stresses with this
can we please call the fbi
i understand that you have taken some
mental health leave in the past why is
that in my file
why don't you run you said you had it
they did
now they don't
kimmy bedtime legs
i'm here
[Music]
[Music]
you